DEBI CABRERA: Hey, everyone.
Today, we're talking about
visual user interfaces, Pub/Sub
Lite, Next '22, and
free cloud training.
I'm Debi Cabrera.
And welcome to "This
Week in Cloud,"
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
At Google Cloud, we're
committed to making
Artificial Intelligence, or
AI, accessible to everyone
and easier to harness
for new use cases.
That's why we're
excited to announce
the general availability of
our intuitive new visual user
interface for Google
Cloud Speech-To-Text, STT,
API right in Google
Cloud Console,
which makes the API much simpler
and easier for developers
to use.
When you build highly resilient
data analytics pipelines,
difficult tradeoffs are common.
Increasing reliability
can come at a cost.
But then pursuing low costs
can mean more hands-on
operational management.
The Cloud Pub/Sub team wants
to give you the flexibility
to optimize for
cost, reliability,
and level of management,
given your workload.
So we're introducing
an additional messaging
option that balances cost
with high availability.
This new Pub/Sub Lite offering
is called "Regional Topics."
Google Cloud is now offering
30 days no-cost access
to Google Cloud Skills Boost,
the definitive destination
for skills development to
complete role-based training.
Choose from eight
learning paths,
including Getting Started with
Google Cloud, Cloud Engineer,
Data Analyst, ML
Engineer, and more.
Hope you're ready
for some excitement
because Google Cloud Next
returns on October 11
through October 13 of this year.
Join us for keynotes
from industry luminaries
and engage live with
Google Developers.
Explore dynamic content across
various learning levels,
and dive deep into
technologies and solutions
spanning the Google Cloud and
Google Workspace portfolios.
You will participate in
breakout sessions, demos,
hands-on training, and hear from
the world's leading companies
about their digital
transformation journeys.
You'll have opportunities
to connect with experts,
get inspired, and
boost your skills.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.